[Music]
so I saw this tweet that went pretty
viral this is the tweet what is say yes
fun fact some people have an internal
narrative and some don't
as in some people's thoughts are like
sentences they hear and some people just
have abstract nonverbal thoughts and
have to consciously verbalize them and
most people aren't aware of the other
type of person oh is that true let me
let me show you how wild that is my wife
just sent me this last week because I
called her talking to herself I was like
she was like what the [ __ ] are you doing
you a crackit cuz I didn't sign up for
this she was like no sometimes I have to
talk stuff out I'm like why don't you
just say it to yourself she was what she
was but I'm not
yeah I'm um but don't all black people
talk stuff out in a movie theater no I
[Applause]
go to the movies in the daytime because
I can't find it now I find it but I'm
gonna show y'all she literally just sent
me that's because we were having that
conversation and I just was like not
never never like you don't meet a like
up talking to yourself like how you need
to do this and you did but it was like a
full-out length but you recorded her
mid-sentence working her [ __ ] out all
out but not in recorder no I was just
saying she's just sent me that article
oh my god show us that article yeah
we're gonna see two different we can see
it on your little article that we
already have he's like yeah buddy no to
you guys what's your email okay fine
we'll do it it's because TIFF put the
[ __ ] black screen on right so you
didn't think it was really there I bet
you wish you work this out on an
internal monologue instead of doing that
I waited this whole time for a video of
your wife talking about her so - I'm
glad I asked [ __ ]
but yeah well do you so you're saying
that you have abstract nonverbal
thoughts and your wife has verbal nuts
and that tripped you out no I think he
has verbal thoughts his wife is abstract
which is why she has to say it I thought
it was if you don't have verbal thoughts
then you have to say because it's all
jumbled up and if you have verbal
thoughts you don't say it oh I guess I
could see how you came to that
conclusion but the way I interpret this
this tweet is the right way like our
feelings yeah that's what that thoughts
are the feelings they're not actual
words so if they have to express what
they're thinking they have to
consciously verbalize it to tell someone
this is what I'm thinking but just on
their own like on their own they will
just have feelings and nonverbal
thoughts so they don't talk they don't
they have to work out their thoughts in
discussion no it's not the verbalizing
to themselves they say it low so isn't
that what your wife is doing talking it
out loud no yes allowed is audible but
she's not like having conversation I
need to do this if she literally just
talking to us up I practice speeches
with myself well yeah that's different I
finally take over a country and my
followers are there looking up at me in
your inner speech yeah you're saying the
words in your head
yeah no I'm saying I'm performing it in
my living room when I'm ready to take
off that's a very different than this
article if really different that's a new
article that's not even close for all of
eternity
method on we're talking about Sona you
just brought up cocaine there's amazing
new I haven't I do kind of want to know
how your speech goes later but yeah but
yeah it was on the passionate fly and I
was naked could I just took a shower
sometimes I work my thoughts throughout
in a shower and I somehow end up in
different parts of my your house my
house are you naked and then you go to
your advisor you're dripping wet too
like wow
cuz you just walked out in the shout at
the living room talking to my piano as
if it was one of my biggest like
followers might you have a piano in your
house yeah it's [ __ ] dope dude I got
it
resize are you naked and you talk to
your adviser and you're like what do you
think of my clothes and he's like sir
you're not wearing and you just shoot
him shoot the piano whoa
imaginary advisor yeah yeah okay I'm not
gonna be naked in real life but he's
dripping wet tip well you could be you
had that I hate being wet outside of the
shower no but have you ever been so far
deep into your imagination that you
don't even realize never never
yeah it's messy but wet this guy stands
into cold water falls now though cuz
it's fun you were you're talking to a
different Joe right now yeah it's
cocaine and tuna like you said that is
okay well I just thought working out
your thoughts was like that so I think
the the the element of like actually
verbalizing them out loud has been
placed into this conversation where I
didn't even I don't know I don't think
they're referring to that I'm just
talking about like just in your head
because some people they have they have
a conversation in their head and then
they verbalize in some people they just
be you feel so that's what this tweeter
center inflating it and they're painting
it very black-and-white but it doesn't
seem to be that black-and-white
according to a clinical psychologist
this psychologist says that they believe
that there's like there's a spectrum
like how people work out their thoughts
and so they're saying that most people
don't even work out their thoughts their
stupid as [ __ ] or like thinking not even
working it out just thinking yeah they
don't even think it's true I think most
people are feelers off most people are
empty most yeah majority of people are
[ __ ] empty would you say the
percentages have you seen a bell curve
before what percentage of people walk
around after a shower or sweat and they
like it
maybe it's close to that maybe some
people are afraid of the cold Steve done
that less than a handful of times in my
life just that thought of water just
dripping out of our body this [ __ ] up
these thoughts in words or feelings or I
was in the middle of a conversation so
it doesn't apply to that now but
pictures were in my mind I didn't like
it is it me why would it be a Giorgio
why I don't know what I pictured it
Richard Joe you picture two here naked
talk my imagination I'm wearing a
military uniform and I'm talking to my
followers but in real life there's like
water dripping down gasps I fixed you
Joe yes
water dripping down and then he had an
imaginary dog like licking his ass Walla
dog licking gels asked he's having the
dictators like a Adolf Hitler speech
stand up for what's right so they're
saying that a lot of people have both in
their mind so what do you guys think you
have do you think you have more words
like actual made outwards or like
pictures and feelings when you're
thinking pictures in failure
I can't think the more I think the more
jumbled up I can [ __ ] something up if
I'm like talking or like if I'm working
something out I have to just talk it out
that's right so did you talk out loud
yeah or do you talk in your head oh yeah
when I'm alone I talk out loud yeah I
just got just yeah I
nail it down to what it is out loud hmm
now I'm in my head a lot
remind it's mainly verbal thoughts so
there's actually sentences and stuff
yeah but then I think when I get caught
off-guard emotionally like let's say me
and Jillian to fight or something and
then did I think it starts getting just
feelings and then when she's like wait
we're not even fighting about what we're
talking about then I'm like oh [ __ ] I
got caught up I got drunk with anger so
I think like if I'm normally I'm able to
have thoughts but then sometimes it I do
go into the feeling realm if you like to
change that off guard yeah because I
think like I think the majority of my
lifetime it's been more like feelings
and like not really images but mainly
feelings is like how I think and then I
noticed that those feelings were always
negative feelings so then now I'm doing
like a conscious effort to turn those
feelings into positive feelings by
verbalizing sentences in my head last
time you like more positive sentences
stop living a horror show
yeah more horror horror movies I
definitely heard horror - oh good bro
it's also hard to listen if you're
thinking hard and so like if you're
communicating with like your wife or
something and you're a thinker person I
find that to be really hard to try to
actually listen and engage with what
they're saying that you're I thinking
about it easy yeah yeah yeah so that so
that's why you know I you know try to do
both but I tried to just bullet point my
thoughts so that way I don't I can
actually be available and listen has he
been like working out his book through
all the conversations because I feel
like that was just chapter 13 I actually
literally thought the book he was trying
to get feedback from you guys
you gave him nothing that was caught
that was active listening that's that
chapters chapter 13 no and of Latinos
well his active listening should be
chapter one it should be in the front no
no no Act
chapter one is he's not listening he
didn't he need to read the book yeah
obviously you were just listening to
respond you weren't actively late
exactly yeah boy like when I said I
would be there at 6:00 a.m. you
responded but you didn't listen okay cuz
you weren't actively listening and then
chapter ones actually trust and you lost
that's [ __ ] gone the thrill is gone
baby boy has no trust yeah I think Joe's
thinking about who wiped those wet
footprints off the floor disappear look
I heard what you were saying something
about 6:00 a.m. you didn't hear you were
gonna go to barbell right and then he
stood you up yeah but before that it was
the relationship book or whatever you've
another point are you really listening I
heard those things right uh-huh
but what I was really thinking about
he's licking my ass buddy no no no it's
more important than that okay okay we're
gonna create the ten laws of my country
and the book has a golden out like it's
it's it's written of gold and it's
leather made by a [ __ ] European
leather like it's perfect it's it's it's
it's me I'm a beginner you have me a
perfect world European of course
European I did European warrior with a
gun to his head so the bullet points you
haven't even worked that out yeah you
just work on the visual yes it was a
visual right right so you guys [ __ ] me
up because I saw a Merlin he pulled out
the this book made out of a European
warrior skin pages are empty made out of
gold okay I didn't even get to open the
page yet that's one so I am a picture of
visual and I'm talking to myself
yeah I'm Harry and I'm doing that and I
see the visual so I like to do both yeah
we're talking about like relationships
if you're thinking about you're here and
I heard it I knew I could read trace the
steps I know what you guys are talking
about just wasn't that important
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]